better make it quick kiddo in five
minutes this place is becoming a
Starbucks this is coffee
some people say that Starbucks are
taking over but there's a starbucks
everywhere that mom-and-pop coffee shops
are being run out of business but is
this really true critics have demanded
that the company be zoned out of
neighborhoods that legislation is needed
to prevent a corporate coffee takeover
but in the past year starbucks stock
price hit a five-year low and it
recently announced it was closing seven
percent of its American stores in
starbucks isn't alone once mighty chain
stores like blockbuster circuit city and
even walmart have experienced decline
and profits and arise in store closures
before America surrendered to the venti
americano the skinny chai and the soy
latte ours was a country that ran on
coffee crystals in powdered cappuccino
brewed into a beverage that is consumed
in the hundreds of millions of couples
each day random Swedes coaxed American
housewives into burnt pots of delicious
canned coffee this one committee member
to another maybe you should say for just
coffee according to the Specialty Coffee
Association of America in 1989 there
were only two hundred independent coffee
houses in the United States this country
didn't have much of a coffee culture so
starbucks created one and today's
starbucks is ubiquitous with over 11,000
outlets in america alone first they
closed all the neighborhood starbucks
what's next they closed the starbucks
under my desk grande took the front of
whole milk latte mom-and-pop coffee
shops have exploded too with an
estimated fifteen thousand stores in
america but after years of breakneck
growth the corporate coffee house is in
retreat wounded by a sluggish economy
declining product quality and an
increasingly competitive market
starbucks the once unstoppable corporate
behemoths is closing 600 american stores
and almost all of their australian
outlets 12,000 managers and baristas
will lose their jobs and in most cases
their health insurance as starbucks
closes stores many independent coffee
shops are growing in Adams Morgan
District of Washington DC the coffee has
triste is for morning tonight at almost
full capacity but in 2004 starbucks
decided that it to wanted to try its
hand in the neighborhood and open just a
half a block away there was definitely a
lot of neighborhood anxiety about what
was gonna happen was his neighborhood
turning into something
they were didn't really want our
preparation for them coming in was just
telling to step up our operation like we
knew that we were going to have a
competitor and competition is good so it
just forces you to heighten your own
policies procedures products things like
that so it actually was good for us many
independent coffee shops have realized
that specialization and local touch are
the best ways to have Frank Starbucks
it's the people that work here is really
what it comes out in the quality of our
products we don't have pushed button
machines we have really well-trained
maurices you care about what they're
doing and the formula seems to be
working this will be Tris fourth store
other local coffee houses are seeing
similar growth neither the seattle
coffee giant nor its competitors are
likely to disappear anytime soon but it
seems that starbucks started believing
its detractors that size and market
sheriff forever that the company was
invincible but as the history of chain
stores like Woolworths and sears
demonstrates this isn't always the case
there's no need to tote signs or to
advocate for zoning restrictions at a
girl trash cans through windows
countless independent coffee shops have
simply beat them at their own game and
as coffee houses like trista found
there's no need to legislate to protest
when you can simply compete for reason
TV I'm Michael Moynihan
has around
damn you mom and pop coffee stores for
forcing starbucks out of business